The shirt!
Oh yeah, you noticed.
Oh, it's kind of wobbly.
That's better.
Love your shirt?
You guys, I ordered it from like a...
So you know when you order something from like Amazon?
And then it comes and it's like...
Like a... like a...
A baby...
You know, like a...
You think you're ordering something, but then they just put
it on a t-shirt?
I thought I was ordering a t-shirt and then...
I thought...
Instead, it was not a PNG shirt.
It was a JPEG shirt!
I kind of got scammed.
I didn't...
I ordered a PNG t-shirt, but instead a JPEG t-shirt came.
Yeah, like when people order like a bedroom set and then
it's a poster of a bedroom.
Hmm.
Oh well, I'll still wear it.
I think it looks good on me anyway.
Was able to get the holo tickets.
Oh, is that today?
I'm not going.
I thought I would go, but I have too much going on in
August.
Have fun for me!
Have fun for me.
Oh, congrats on getting the tickets.
Also, Lost in the Store, they give her the 10 gifted.
And Curry Ninja, they give her the 5 gifted.
Thank you, thank you.
Not a fan of those wet pea shirts that are popping up
recently.
I can, I see the problem with that.
the seam doesn't connect to the collar so the white fill
took up the whole box oh you're right oh gosh they just
don't make things like they used to anymore
but anyway welcome um this will be a pretty short stream um
i just got home like an hour ago and i was like i must i
must watch this watch a long i must do it or i must do a
watch along of this because i've been waiting all day how
was your trip it was good it was i actually i will not say
anything about it right now you will hear about it
eventually hopefully within like a week i got paid so i'm
here to pay the mint phantom tax there's no tax Thank you
for the super tapichi.
I love magnesium sulfide too.
What a coink you think.
Saving it for the podcast?
I'm saving it.
Yeah, pretty much.
Which actually, we gotta record that tomorrow.
Hold on, let me message Matara.
You.
You still.
Still good for the podcast.
tomorrow recording
haruka thank you for the gifted thank you heard something
about tax no the little boss good to have you oh my god why
is there so much this is what's happening taxing no no no
what's happening why are there so many super chats all of a
sudden matthews thank you nerdy thank you deliran thank you
spank thank you Thank you guys.
I know nothing of this.
So basically, Konami had this Metal Gear production hotline
number one.
So we're going to be getting more than one of these, which
is kind of crazy.
And it's only like 20 minutes long, as you can see.
I don't know at all what will be talked about.
Stop!
watch along V and but I think they will be talking about
Metal Gear and I like that so I'm gonna watch it will it
even be in English it literally says in the title with
English subtitles so you're good you're Gucci you're Gucci
you're all Good.
No worries.
Just heard about the Mifet, the Mifet, the Mifet.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I'm Murphy.
Thanks for the vibe.
Gifted.
Oh my gosh.
TK.
Thank you for the pink.
Don't worry, guys.
I've got the tags this time.
YAMERA-ROW!
Sayonara, Oka-N-E.
Okay.
Watch a long ticket.
This is getting out of hand.
I would like to watch this now, please.
May I?
May I watch this?
I've been waiting patiently all day.
Bravo chief, thanks to the vibe, good to...
Choco minto, tax, tax, tax!
Minto, stinky?
I'm starting.
I'm ignoring you guys now.
She hates our money.
This is my tax refund.
I am paying my taxes.
Um, it's 20 minutes and 57 seconds for you.
Well, look at you living in 2035.
We're all here in 2024.
That's when they introduced that they can edit videos and
they added in one extra second to say Frick roll Can you
imagine?
That's what they put in the extra second is what it says
Good bit, boss Shut up I love MSG No, no, I okay, you scared
me for a second you thought i thought i accidentally wrote
that i mean bought that what if i got a shirt that says i
heart msg i believe that it exists mint tax remember to let
go all those nerd energy nerd energy i do love msg though
you know what me too i like msg also makes things taste real
They're just going to talk.
We're just going to react to this.
Sorry, I'm a react YouTuber now.
Stop thinking about the pig loss.
Mint tax.
This is ridiculous.
I hope you're happy.
Madison Square Garden.
No, no, no, no.
That would be the MSG.
Madison Garden Square.
They renamed it to fix the...
You know, they misprinted all of these t-shirts.
They were like, we can't sell this.
There's nothing in the world called MGS.
And so they were like, we'll just rename it from Madison
Square Garden to Madison Garden Square.
TK.
Thank you for the 50 gift.
Thank you.
What the heck?
Thank you so much.
I want to talk about my trip.
But I will refrain.
I will refrain.
I'll talk about it another day because right now metal gear
time okay so let me turn off my music let me turn the volume
up here let me move out of the way i'm gonna cover you guys
so everybody can see my cool shirt here i'll even here there
we go i want everybody to see my cool shirt why are you guys
sending so much talk talk it is e-o-f-y what is that wait
what does that mean
Embodiment of Phantom Year Oh,
end of fiscal year Oh, I got the year part right I'm such a
genius End of Phantom Year No, and then I just disintegrate
Like Thanos snapped me out of existence We love our ghostly
bust in mind session with tactical espionage action oh my
gosh my bag shipped my my my metal gear bag i'm so excited i
heart mgs mint ghost stream room let me guys let me know let
me let me know guys if you would like this as official um
official t-shirt merch it would not be a t-shirt that says i
heart mgs it would be a t-shirt of this t-shirt that says i
heart mgs
A t-shirt of a t-shirt.
I haven't watched this either.
I hope it's cool.
I hope so too!
I'm excited to hear more stuff about Delta.
And like I said, I don't really know what else.
I think some people were speculating that there might be
talks of the Master Collection number two.
So maybe we'll see.
I don't know.
Everything's a mystery.
I heart MF.
Are you a MF?
Are you a MFer?
mgs4 please i know right all right are you guys ready um
there's not really a countdown because i'm just gonna play
it on the screen but um we'll watch it it's only 20 minutes
and then we can talk more afterwards sound good sound good
ready we are mf her it's me i'm mf her oki doki sounds good
oki doki i'm just gonna play and i can adjust the audio as
we go give me one second too okay it needs to be a mint
ghost solid t-shirt with you and a liquid snake caught why
am i in a liquid snake costume you're just trying to get me
shirtless you sneaky i see right through your plans baby car
thanks to the gifted
good now yeah liquid you guys is naked he i mean not naked
he has no shirt on please god peace walker a master
collection part two all right let's start we won't
my next video is busting
no that's so funny That's so funny It knows, it really does
know Okay Metal Gear Production Hotline I wonder why they
started Oh, let me move the Oh, let me move the
Oh my god, that's the opening!
It's the opening!
It's the, like the credits!
The, the, the...
MC, I'm Momoyama Tsukika.
Yes, yes, yes.
And, again, again, with the members I'll go show it to show.
First, I'm Pro-Motion-Tantone Oh, Ishiiro-san.
they're going so fast.
I can't really feel like I can't comment.
Oh, Ishiiro, Hello!
Hello!
Hey!
Let's get the new main menu!
Main menu!
People weren't worried that it wasn't going to come back,
but it did!
Everybody freaks out so easily.
Oh!
I'm freaking it.
Metal Gear Online's two-tack-me-de-were director.
Metal Gear Rising, Metal Gear Survive-de-will producer.
Delta, as MGS5-2, creative producer to the production and
the studio.
Okay, wow, so he's been around.
Thank you.
How's the audio?
I'll turn it off just a little bit.
The instrumental is making me emotional.
First reveal!
Technical previews!
This is good?
Okay.
You read that script.
Wait, what does the SE stand for?
Metal Gear...
Oh, Snake Gear.
Oh, gosh, I'm so scared to run.
You guys, I'm going to...
Editor, cut that from the VOD, please.
As soon as I like said it, then it just...
Oh, it came to me.
Oh, this is the one that they showed before, right?
Oh, it looks so good.
Oh!
Farametic looks so cute.
They added like the lens flare from 5.
That's gonna be me.
This mission was sneaking mission.
Where's the P filter?
It's toggleable.
They've already said that.
That's gonna be me.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, I love that the crock mouth kind of opens and
closes.
It's so cute.
Ew, God, he's gross.
Oh my gosh, I bet he tastes like a wild beast.
Okay, the one thing is he better do his little flips in the
air.
I swear.
They took that out of the patchy slot can.
Speak.
Oh, there was us alive!
Yeah!
Blow him up!
There he is.
The boss.
Oh, it's such a good trailer.
Oh, it's so good.
I was...
Did they...
For the Japanese, actually, I don't know.
Yeah, it's a very cool video.
Yeah!
It is really good in Japanese though.
But...
I love the English.
I love so much.
Metal Gear Production Hotline.
Oh!
It's like one of those rare series that I play in English,
you know.
They speak English canonically.
They're speaking Russian sometimes.
One is visual.
Visual.
Oh, look at that little crack.
Oh, gee.
Oh, my God.
The Russian.
jungles.
Little crab!
He's a frog!
We've seen all these though.
Look at these for Delta's signify change.
Silly-kidda-fuk, dand-con-darken-darken-the-fuk, all game
play shows.
Look at how muddy he is.
Oh!
Oh my god, he's actually got like bullet holes and stuff.
They only added that to Metal Gear Solid or to MGS3.
Ah!
Haley added it in the 3DS version.
But playing this game on the 3DS is a...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, wait.
Oh, wait.
Oh, God.
Wait, who's asking for this?
Oh, wait.
Ah!
Oh!
Wait.
It's like...
Not pissy enough.
I think.
Oh, I think.
Paul is asking for full Sophia mode.
The Instagram filter really gets me though.
We want to go.
I want to write in a question!
I don't even know what I would ask though.
I would ask, can I play the game right now?
Can I get the game right now?
Really, it looks like they're paying attention to the
criticisms, which I think is good to
Yes.
Why are there more people saying it's very bad over bad?
Oh, goodness.
But, you know, the last time I didn't do anything, but Metal
Gear Solid Delta's new So they were like, it was fine, but
we want to see more for the most part.
Oh my God.
This is so much text.
People tend to choose extreme options.
I guess that's true.
Especially some, I don't know, Japan's kind of.
Even the bad and negative, you can't even do a simple
remaster right off.
Metal Gear is dead and you're the ones who killed it!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, they're brave!
This is a level of self-awareness that I did not expect to
see from them.
Oh my god!
I'm giving you the benefit of the doubt.
as positive and not neutral.
Give us English subs.
This is a brave conference.
I respect this a lot, actually.
I think I respect this a lot.
More than so than just, like, you know, kind of like, you
know.
Thinking they're the shit, you know.
They kind of realize that people are...
critical of them.
I'm doing years of bed.
They are dedicated.
I think it helps that you have so many, You're rather you
have a handful of people from the original so they
understand how important this is.
Like the original devs or, you know, team.
There we go.
Are there any other questions for the original staff of the
Metal Gear series' Oh, maybe they're saying outside the
company if they would come back.
Well, yeah, well, yeah, well, yeah, of course, that's what I
mean, as well as, you know, Kojima, Kukume, staff, and the
staff of the staff, again,
that's what I mean, that's what I mean.
You allowed to say that?
But, but, you know, that's already a new way.
in the same time.
that are on the that is why That's it.
That's why we all know what?
Oh my God!
That's why we're that's why it's not going to be that's why
you have to say that.
Oh my god!
Wait, so they're gonna be also in...
They're gonna be credited in Delta!
So that's why, please.
Yeah, so original staff or staff Oh my god!
Oh my god!
Okay, so the Japanese is also the same.
So they had to read, probably, redo some of that stuff.
That makes sense, though.
So, that's why I said, that's why I don't know what's wrong
with that's why.
So in that part, that's why I'm trying to do a new thing.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, Grimmy!
Thanks for the word!
But it's not uncommon for them to have a bunch of recorded
lines and stuff and...
And...
...be able to...
...be able to mix and match stuff.
I don't know.
Who knows if it's AI?
...who knows if it's AI.
Yeah, splicing.
Yeah, yeah.
She's so cute.
Are you really good with it?
Yeah.
very partner but also if the person is like you know not
available and that they have are not of this realm anymore i
don't think it can be helped so that's right i am curious
about the series a lot of series.
So, that's why I put back four!
That's why the first thing you should first think about
Snake Eater really?
That's why I thought.
That's why.
There are many people who haven't played there are a lot of
people.
That's why I said, if you're worried about that,
I don't believe it.
But I don't believe it.
Where they sort of, where they sort of are bust.
Those are some good questions.
What they picked?
Gosh, they actually picked that first one.
They're so brave.
Oh my God.
I feel like my love for my fans and everyone's love.
I feel like my responsibility was more and more than I feel
like I feel like I feel like that.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Let's all send in our thoughts.
Let's all send in our questions.
Oh my gosh.
I'm a VTuber.
Ending this.
I have VTuber related questions.
Can I be in the game?
Oh!
I pre-ordered that.
I'm so excited.
I love the art for it so much.
I'm excited to just display it.
Put me on the box just like the pods.
I can't.
Because...
Because basically...
The...
I think of it also how like the technology advances, you
know.
Going from MGS3 to MGS1 or MGS3?
To MGS5 to MGS1?
It's just so much.
in terms of like, you know, other, if you go and really
sort, AIMRA!
Cushion!
Oh my god!
Not the tumblers!
I'm sorry, I love- Ah!
Oh my god, they're so!
How cute!
No!
Oh my god!
They're so cute!
No!
Oh my god!
They're so cute!
YouTube in the video link or Metal Gear Koshikix to the link
or post it to the link, so please do.
Thank you.
So, this is Metal Gear Production Hotline's home-highest day
1st time, but how about that?
Next time, we'll be more information about it.
And, um, well, actually, I'll say more one thing.
Wait, before we go, it's almost over?
This is a right in the video.
Oh wait,
so wait, you can, it's either one?
Oh, yeah.
Can I see more of the game?
New style and legacy style of the title damage.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
So each one is different.
Ah, okay.
That's it!
Too short.
Oh my god.
Why did it look so good?
Oh!
Man.
Man!
I wanted to see more of the game.
What is this?
I was hoping to see more of the game.
Oh, wow.
Oh, I don't remember what music I had before.
I didn't think it was this one.
Maybe.
Gotta do frame-by-frame analysis now.
Hold on, yeah.
Actually, I do want to go back to these plushies.
Sorry.
Let me go back to these plushies.
Where are they?
Where are the plushies?
Busting is up.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, where are they?
Oh my gosh.
And a floor!
You guys?
I'm not even kidding you.
You know those places where you can, like...
Okay, so there's sometimes places...
Hold on, everybody needs to see my t-shirt.
There are places where you can, like, go and make your own
rug.
You basically, like, bring in a design and they print it out
for you, and then they help you, like...
And you make it yourself.
You're like, and I was gonna do that with the foxhound.
but I was like, there's no way, like, it's too detailed, it
wouldn't look good.
But I really wanted it.
But now I could just get a mad end on cushion!
I don't really care about the newer Foxhound logo.
I care about middle Foxhound logo.
I like this one.
I like this one the most.
I think it's the most iconic.
It's official too.
I know!
Thank you so much for the vibe, Captain!
Hold on.
This one.
the tumblers wait so is it oh yes okay so this must be the
front and the back and then you have MGS 1 2 and 3 but the
original metal look at the original metal gear okay what the
hell is going on are there like three rays there they look
so cute though yeah you can see the shagohad kind of peeking
out from the corner Sally's such a pixel man.
Oh my gosh.
Raiden is a skinny legend here.
What's up with that?
Rex Ray and the Shagohan.
The rays.
Yeah, it's interesting, though, that they put multiple.
I mean, I guess you do fight multiple.
It's just funny.
Before the thickening.
I can't wait to drink out of these and only...
these actually no I own some metal gear mugs it's uh two
three and peace walker I believe are the only three that
they that they released and I don't use them though I keep
them in my in my cabinet like or rather my like store like I
keep them with my metal gear collection these are shot
glasses no I think these are like full-size tumblers like a
like a regular cup stainless steel tumbler yeah printed with
iterations metal gear and snake and the other characters
hiding in the rivers and
gosh there's this left oh there's so cute oh
my god they're so they're so cute oh i can't i just look at
them and i cry
oh oh some music oh my gosh their little feet sticking out i
can't wait wait i wonder how big they are I'm gonna waste
all my money at the machines at the claw machines
they're so cute
I love plushies pocket size I can't tell if they're pocket
sized I'm gonna have to get like 50 of them don't cry boss I
can't help it last thing right yeah and then at the
beginning here too they were talking about like the stains
and battle damage yeah the leaves like it's so great and
he's got look at that guy right there i love crocodiles you
have a box of tissues at their desk for the next episode why
is it like doing that though when he's walking by Look how
gross he looks!
Oh my god, he's a muddy man!
Rain drop.
Choco chip is back!
Go to naked.
Yippee!
The vein!
Snake, Snake, you look cold.
Snake, you look cold.
Put on a t-shirt.
Please.
I offer you the shirt off my back.
Cover those up, sir.
Wait, he needs to be disaffected.
Actually, they are covered.
No nip, no nip slips for you guys.
He is covered, actually.
He's a modest man.
Oh my god, he looks...
Oh, he can't stop!
I need to stop!
Even his back!
Oh my god.
He looks so good.
Ocelot's gonna freak!
He's such a tease.
Yeah!
New style.
How did he know where to aim that thing?
I can't believe we can crouch run though now I don't know
what do you guys think of the filter I guess it does look
pretty similar to the old to the original now that I'm you
know I think it just looks jarring to me because
I think it looks jarring to me at first because like I'm
used to seeing it this color in in, in, you know, not
high-deaf graphics.
Yeah, too much detail.
I think it could be, I think it looks a little dark.
Maybe that's it.
Like, it could be a little bit brighter and a little bit
more yellow-y.
But also, we're only seeing it in, like, minimal scenes, you
know?
So, so we don't know.
It could be, it could look better in, like, you know.
But also, whoa!
Who is...
Who...
Who is making this...
Who asked for this?
I like this.
Such a lust for Sephia.
Who?
Sephia?
I'm really curious how HD Ocelot will look meowing.
I didn't know, right?
If you want to feel like old cat, like, oh, this is like,
you know, you were like, oh my gosh.
I actually called Konami personally for this.
Oh my gosh.
You did it.
Best filter.
Okay, this one I can forgive.
It's, it's, it's this one.
Oh, okay.
It's Instagram yasafide snake that I don't know what to do
with.
My eyes.
It says retro, but it's literally, it's literally, it's,
they're gonna have like speed runs for like the different
speed runs sepia, speed run retro filter.
This is just an Instagram filter though.
We do have multiple color filters you can change between,
applicable whether you are playing new style or legacy
style.
One option closely recreates the original palette so you can
play with your preferred look.
So what was it?
Okay hold on.
So this, oh nope that's not normal.
That's not normal, that's not normal.
This is normal And then
No!
Why are you lying to me?
This is legacy I'm trying to go back and forth more quickly
But it's like the little preview is lying to me You see
that?
Normal?
Legacy see j
and l oh wow what
isn't that hold on let me pull up a picture metal gear solid
three just so i can have like a visual in my face visual
let's see let me pick um
lighter greens hold on let's see I'm just trying to find a
screenshot of him like standing in the forest snake eater
I don't want to use this picture but it might be the best
thing hold on sorry I'm trying to find a decent picture to
pull up on the screen maybe this one
Thank you!
Have you seen the edit where someone put David Hader in
Laurie Allen's face?
I did!
Where they put him on the snake in the boss?
It does look really good.
I have seen it.
Okay, so this is what we have and this is what is like...
I think it only looks...
It actually is pretty accurate.
I think again, it only looks different because...
Well, actually the one from the...
original the original one looks a little bit more blue-hued
but I think it's just because it's higher deaf it looks
different yeah less foggy but the color is actually pretty
accurate pretty similar and then when you compare it to the
normal yeah again I think it's like the fog and the just the
blurriness of like the ps you know the ps2 so that's gonna
you know that's just it's just lower quality i think there's
more blue hints blue hues rather in the in the original
though from what i can see oh sorry can we get an option we
get a lower poly i know that would be so fun that would be a
really good like camo to have or you know how like at the
beginning you're just like i like mgs3 i like mgs2 i like
metal gear solid you know how you can pick that at the
beginning if you pick i like metal gear solid 3 that it
gives you um a mask that has snake's ps2 face i think would
be funny
can't wait to play with the retro filter
Hmm.
Yeah, so it's not so... it's actually pretty accurate.
And it does say that they're, you know, they're closely
recreating the original palette.
I think they...
I mean, that was a huge people, a huge complaint from
people, so...
And Drago, thanks for the 10 gifted!
This though.
I... hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Also, we skipped over some... where's the quest... this
is... where's the Shizu-mon corner?
Oh, it was after- wait.
Here, here, here, here.
Here, here, here, here, here.
Is there any chance that the original staff members will
return to work on co-develop or supervise any of the Metal
Gear series?
This!
This?
I bit my tongue.
This!
Hello?
I'm shocked It's not my place to answer on behalf of anyone
outside of the company Or to guess how they might feel about
it But just speaking for myself personally But they, but The
fact that Konami allowed him to say this Really surprises me
You know?
To work with Kojima and the rest of the team again, if that
could happen, that would be a dream.
That's insane!
I wonder how Kojima sound feels about that.
I just want to hear a second ask me why I'm naked when I
call him.
And he will.
Patience.
I'm very...
Very curious.
Up until now, it seemed like they tried to do it.
everything to not say kojima yeah um i i'm i i see comments
in the chat and i will not read them you guys have your own
opinions and such i would like to one day be sponsored
So I will just say that this is probably the most shocking
thing of the whole hotline.
But my favorite part is not him.
Are these.
This chat loves Konami.
I only just realized we can spin snake.
Oh yeah, can we spin snake and make him sick in the menu?
I sure hope so.
Oh my gosh, I want to make him barf.
I want to make this man barf.
Look, look, look.
This is a guy who's ready to barf.
That's a good question to send.
I think, yeah, I think maybe a good question would be how
many features from the game will be in the remake such as
like you know that and what new features will they be or i
guess they can't say what new or rather will the old
features be kept and will any new features be added you know
i think what people when you talk about you know when you
talk about the relationship
Both parties, rather.
I think, first of all, literally no one in this chat was
there.
And also, you know, time.
I think times are different, and so you can't always think
that opinions that once were are the same.
Actually, I'm John Konami.
so I don't know I'm more of an optimist I suppose in that
regard where I feel like that relationships because you know
I've you know I've had friendships end and then rekindle so
I think that relationships between things can be salvaged so
that's my opinion on stuff that's all you know And people
like money.
So true.
And I think with Kojima-san, he definitely still loves Metal
Gear.
He is always retweeting stuff about it.
And tweeting stuff himself about it.
So, you know, I would never, I would not say, you know,
never say never.
So.
Yeah.
That's all.
I like money too.
Oh my gosh.
What a co-winky thing.
But yeah.
You're saying professional relationships can blove even in
the board.
Perhaps.
I don't know about love, though.
Contractual.
Something.
Contractual love.
Is there such thing as an absolute timeless enemy?
There's no such thing and never has been.
And the reason is that our enemies are human beings like us.
They can only be our enemies in relative terms.
So metal gear.
But, um, will the movement be the same as MGS5?
It's hard to say.
They didn't show us anything.
They just said that there's remake mode and then there's...
There's remake mode and then there's...
Legacy mode.
But also...
Hold on.
I didn't see...
What do they include in this timeline?
We've seen this before though, right?
This is on the website.
Where's Snake's Revenge?
That's the real Metal Gear 2!
Where is it?
Mint becomes a Metal Gear news channel.
Feels a little like that, huh?
She likes money.
Get her!
Where's portable ops?
Yeah, they actually didn't put in portable ops.
No ghost babble, no portable ops.
I mean, acid, of course, wouldn't be in here, but...
Yeah, where's ape escape?
No rising.
make sense because this is a Metal Gear Solid timeline.
And that's Metal Gear Rising.
Not Metal Gear Solid.
So you can take that one to the bank.
Metal Gear Rising too.
Metal Gear Solid Delta Peace Walker.
I wonder... I do feel like they'll continue making these.
But also...
I don't know.
I don't know how I feel about it, about them doing.
I mean, they don't need to do all the games, obviously.
Like, Phantom Pain's totally fine.
Even I'd say MGS4 is fine.
Oh, I hate money.
Get away, get away from me, money!
Rule of nature.
And then they did also say that, you know, the old team in
Kojima's name will be...
I don't know.
It was kind of confusing.
They said it was for the...
for the Master Collection, but they didn't really mention if
it was for Delta.
They kind of scooted around that one.
Do you think it was braver to name Drop Kojima or MGM
Survive?
I think this whole this thing, this whole this whole
hotline, I don't even know what to call it.
This whole segment was so brave.
Like the questions, like this, this!
Metal Gear is dead and you're the ones who killed it
Like wow Wow And then they took that comment and put it on
the screen They probably received like thousands of comments
and they were like Man this one really This one's barely
tell And then they read it out last It just felt like with
the negative ones it just felt like arrow after arrow after
also this one based They actually let us type whatever we
want here based Wait I didn't see that one the first time Oh
my god
Oh my god that's so funny Who who had to translate that for
them But, um, it's funny because the positive ones are so,
like...
Like, kind of neutral.
I feel like you really do care, so I'm giving you the
benefit of the doubt.
It's like, don't fuck it up, you guys.
Seeing Konami be ready to talk so openly with the fans is
really great.
This one's good.
This one's nice.
But it's also, like, kind of throwing shade, though, because
they're just like, they're talking openly, because
everyone's shit talking, you guys.
How did they translate base and JPEG?
I can't read the kanji, so I can't tell you.
Bring on some of the other MGS Delta's snake eater dev
staff, too.
Can we see more gameplay or first reveal stuff?
Yeah, we didn't really see...
I guess first reveal stuff for this would be the survival
menu.
Was kind of all we got.
English subs.
You should answer more questions at a time.
Baisudo.
Ah, I think, yeah.
And then, bugs that impact gameplay should have been fixed
before release.
This is about the master collection, obviously.
You'll probably do a bad job on the next game, too, so I'd
rather you just came up!
You can't even do a simple remaster, right?
No punches pulled What I like about them showing this though
Is that they are actually like It seems that they will read
this And be like okay we'll prove them wrong You know like
with the Master Collection It did when it first came out
Saying that there were You know you can't say that there
were no issues But they have gone They have done so much to
fix them And I believe that the Master Collections and
beyond in what they offered in terms of like extra bonus
stuff like with the soundtracks and the um like orchestral
remakes of the songs and the scripts and adding like you
know snakes revenge you know so there's i mean obviously
it's positive and negative yeah the comics like they really
it really like when they first were talking about it it felt
like that they were putting out a lot of care.
And so, um, you know, when there were all the buggy issues
with it, and people were rightfully upset, you know.
But,
they're still working on it, and it's not unusual right now
for buggy releases to get left that way.
showing this level of negativity is a sign of them trying to
show their sincerity I think that's how I feel about it too
right like I feel like this is this is these are really bad
comments so I actually respect it you know I actually
respect that they kind of put that out there this is really
bad and then this let us type whatever we want here and then
they put it on the Then they choose it!
Oh my gosh, what was this?
This was all kind of like gone over pretty quickly.
And then even this, what did you think of the March episode?
Only 52% said it was pretty good.
Like we're very good.
Oh, information about Master Collection, Volume 2.
MGO nitsaite.
Oh.
Behind, okay, there's nothing else.
Pretty good.
Why didn't they say...
Why didn't they translate it as pretty good?
Well, I mean, I guess tote mo yo-kato does not mean pretty
good.
It means very good.
But, you know, come on.
Just do the joke.
Do the joke.
E sense da.
Yeah, what else would you like to see in the hotline?
new info yeah give me new info what would other be maybe
like merchandise which we did kind of get that they should
give revenge in the twin snake style remake where the
cutscenes are crazier and even more over the top yeah snake
docky snake undies
When are we getting this?
It was only released in Europe.
They released like a Shadow Moses perfume.
Oh, wait, not perfume.
Cologne.
I tried to buy it, but I couldn't.
Snake Fumo.
That reminds me.
I haven't checked Amiami today to see if...
To see if...
Oh, my bad.
Don't look at my stuff.
To see if there was a...
New, the snake Figma is up yet.
There we go.
Ami, ami.
I love private email.
That's my business email.
I told you don't look.
Wait, what is in here?
Amazon.
Why is that pinned?
Unpin.
I didn't put that there.
Here, I'll even read it to you, okay?
YouTube private email calendar.
Twitter X?
Why are they two separate things?
Google Drive, Studio, YouTube, and Ami Ami are my, all my
recent things, okay?
Oh, wait, I'm not going to Twitter.
I instinctually click Twitter.
Okay, Ami Ami.
Oh my gosh, Ayami!
Her figure is up for pre-order on here!
Okay, I'll pre-order it.
Hold on, I want this.
You guys, hold on.
Wait.
Okay, good.
I'm not laughing.
I want that.
She's just licking the floor.
Here, look at the Ayami one.
It's kind of spicy.
It's not even that expensive.
It's actually a decent price.
It's actually pretty.
25.
Oh!
Woo!
YouTube, don't flag me.
This is art.
It's artwork.
Pre-order fun.
Thank you.
What else is on here?
There's a REM.
Birthday cake REM.
Okay.
i think i've seen that one before bye bye bye yen is at an
all-time low still no snake though i don't see him at least
oh the price oh my god oh it's just so expensive
oh look how cute her faces though it's really cute but i
gotta i gotta figure that's um hold on i'll show you let's
see if i can find it even the one that i pre-order i wanted
this i wanted these two ones also this one i love how like
softer hair looks and it's not a bad price kana is the
genius child who licks baking soda.
Yeah.
What is your special?
Oh, I can't even read that word.
I'm the genius ghost who...
Uh.
Who's always busting?
Yeah.
I'm the genius ghost who's always busting.
Let's see.
That was like some time ago.
They released...
So much Yudercamp merch.
Sorry that it's all kind of cut off.
I don't feel like resizing.
I like how this is just delved into a Miami-Amy Street.
It wasn't this long ago, though, I don't think.
Uh-oh, does that mean the order date's coming up?
It wasn't that long ago.
I just want to get the figure.
I just want the new Figma.
The new Snake Figma.
Where is my figure that I ordered?
No Metal Gear merch?
I wonder, actually.
Metal Gear.
Oh, still, you can see what I searched for before.
Get out of here.
Oh my god.
Pecora.
Stop!
Don't call me!
Get
out of the Metal Gear menu, you guys.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
It's all old stuff though.
I think this is like the only thing that you probably would
be able to get because yeah They re-released it
I feel like I'm being exposed in so many ways.
This is why I never window or never yeah, this is why I
never show my windows Oh,
I don't know I want Let's see, I got one recently, but it
was secondhand.
Let me see, I think they have, they should have it on here.
This.
I got this one.
Oh no, just kidding.
Sorry.
Wrong, wrong, wrong, wrong.
No, this one.
I got the Peace Walker play arts figure.
so um i got that second hand recently and i got the figure
of snake with a fat ass i'm so excited for that one oh my
gosh look at him i need him i need this man
look at them standing next to me
Oh my god, his glasses.
Look at him posing.
Oh, I need this guy.
Why doesn't he come with a hamburger?
The mask is a little kinky, though.
I think the mask is a little...
Wow.
Why do the aviators look like...
poop what are you talking about they don't at all
also i love you guys can't see it but i'm going to click on
this and you're gonna be like why was this under metal gear
like i i know why because of the the title of the figure but
it's also very funny it's because it's simple gear and then
the bunny suit is metallic red so it's under here i don't
remember her oh i have this ryden i found him at a
second-hand store before once in japan i have this the um i
bought it from here actually i wanted the amyami pass case
so i have that
blame otacon yeah these are such good like this is a really
expensive one but these other figure prices are pretty
decent well this one's expensive too but
i have oh this one took me forever to find simple gear
mention this took for me forever to find and i didn't want
it in the black version i wanted it in the original version
but i own this and mine didn't come with stickers oh no I've
been ripped off what mine didn't come with stickers I've
been robbed but it's I didn't want the one in black I wanted
it oh oh my god sorry I just opened up my phone because I
was checking a notification.
But I was listening to TikTok.
I don't know if you heard it.
Mine didn't have stickers.
But also, I don't even see the stickers applied onto here.
So what's the point?
Art book.
D-Dog.
Guilty gear.
Only heard a little.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, this is the one I got.
Look how cute...
I had to get...
Well, not the only reason, but the biggest reason I wanted
it was because of these guys.
I needed the tiny...
Look at his abs.
They're so small!
I had to have them.
And look how cute Rex is.
Oh, my gosh.
I think it's one of the favorite things I own.
I wonder if they have, uh...
Oh, wow.
There's a Metal Gear Solid 3D.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, God.
What is this?
This is so, so sad.
Who are you?
What?
his cheek go in there this is at least i didn't put pies
right because that would be even more depressing but god his
face here looks so funny oh gosh whoo i want the i want the
skull face kind of wait no that i did not i did not just see
a cage i did not just see a cage i did not just see
This is so Oh my god he's going after that guy This is kind
of fun I like this a lot actually I wonder if it comes with
all of this This is wild
Oh my god I'm crying It's so funny They know what they were
doing Oh my gosh I kind of want it so I can put everybody in
the cage.
I want everybody in the baby jail.
Oh my god.
I wish it was still for sale.
Oh, send me back.
When was this release?
2015.
Send me back.
Oh, this is so...
This whole set is...
Wow.
That's my favorite thing.
Put chat in the cage?
Oh, I will.
Oh, here we go.
It's tiny.
Why is the picture so small?
Chico Child Soldier POW version cage and trauma included.
Pye's stomach bomb die.
Oh my god.
It's so small.
We're getting into like the non-metal gear stuff.
The Peace Walker.
small more sinful gear i like they came out with these cases
they had like an i droid case but they also came out with
these like actual metal cases and i want to get the i droid
one because i see it pretty often on for sale um imagine a
friend enters your room and asks you why do you have a scale
model of a kid in a cage i know right but yeah i don't have
any can't justify getting them because I would have to I
would never be able to use them but the iDroid one is so
cool I was like if I I don't know mod it or something
there's no way there's no way so much sinful gear what is
metal fear metal fear notebook do
you guys want to to see my recently viewed items they're at
the bottom look at this creepy
carby yeah car what is this though it says metal gear
notebook 2012 top features four snakes and personal data and
metal gear appearing in the title what does that mean
different famous Quotes of characters are printed for each
day.
Is it just a calendar?
A 2012 calendar?
Seven title stories are summarized.
Many screenshots used.
Worlds of Metal Gear can be enjoyed with gaming language.
Well, I love gaming language.
I see you ogling Ayami.
I'm going to get that.
I'm going to get that Ayami figure.
Dunn.
Okay, last page.
It's all Peace Walker.
Oh wait, what are these?
Oh wait, I've seen these before.
Yeah, the ultra detail ones.
They look really good actually.
I do really like these because they have all snakes except
liquid and solidus.
But you know.
They'd rather put a mask over old snake than include liquid
all it is.
I would kill for MGS 4 figures.
These ones you can find occasionally on Mercari.
Yeah, the playable snakes.
There you go.
That's a better way to put it.
What?
They also don't have MGS 1 snake.
Thank you, Mint.
I'm going to pre-order that BAU.
It's good, right?
Oh, sorry.
There's a... There's a... There's a...
There's a...
Is Yuko is not up for pre-order?
Oh, she is.
Okay.
I was like, why aren't you... Oh, whoa!
There's even more down here.
They're really cute.
They're really, really cute.
I'm kind of debating.
Sudden Blue Archive.
Always Blue Archive.
Look.
You guys... When will they...
invent squishable figures?
Actually, they have.
I have a figure that has a, um, it's cast off.
Um, it's smaller, but the boobs are squishy.
So why won't they make the tummy squishy too?
Come on!
Pop-up parade!
The formable materials are harder to cast.
It's 2024!
We have to make use of all of our technology.
like cheerleader hippie so cute oh my god i want to
pre-order it i'm still deciding if i should or not i'm
trying to cut down a little bit i really like this toky also
or rather i want this toky but i don't know if i like her
face there's something about it that doesn't there's
something off about it especially in this photo i don't know
something off about her face
not smug enough no toki is not a smug character i got a
figure with squishy thighs there is hope
sounds like an idea for future merch squishable minto figure
where would i be squishable at actually don't answer that I
don't want don't want to answer that like she looks better
in some like this picture she looks good I think I don't
know I think the face is just a little off for me though
okay we're done I'm done window shopping I'm done window
shopping
time for real shopping well guys this was fun thanks for
letting me um watch that thanks for um watching it all
together oh hold on i have to put my advertisements i'm so
sorry advertisements ha oh wait they're supposed to be
behind me there we go squishy mint figure I guess like maybe
ectoplasm right the mint stream the rare place where in the
same sitting you view merch of military what are you talking
about we didn't look at any any anything that was 18 plus
maybe maybe some stream will will um We'll...
Uh...
Shop Ami Ami or something.
We can do something like that if you guys would be...
Not shop, but window shop.
If you guys would be interested.
Maybe something like that.
Anyway.
Thank you guys for letting me fan out.
Fan out.
I'm all fanned out.
Fan girl out a little bit.
And also window shop.
while I was looking for Snake on AmiAmi.
But he was not there.
I'm so sad.
Tomorrow we'll be playing more Metal Gear.
So if you were just like, wow.
Not enough Metal Gear today, Minto.
Well, then you can check us out tomorrow.
Now we just finished Air Combat.
East Combat 1.
It was a pain experience.
You did it though.
Nice shirt, nerd.
Thank you.
Even though I got scammed.
If you don't know what I mean, watch the beginning of the
stream.
But yeah.
Otsumito!
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Get some rest.
It's the weekend, baby.
It's the weekend party.
Otsumito, otsumito, otsumito.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Bye-bye.
that I'm searching on mommy.
Don't judge me.
Okay.
Don't judge me for what I searched on.
On me, on me.
Okay.
Your face changed.
Face searches, though.
I will get last.
Okay, everybody, let Evan have last I guess.
Top it down.
Can you blame me though looking for Freerun?
They have like the new plushie but I don't like Freerun's
eyes on the plushie so I don't think I...
Like they have the one where she's like in the in the mimic
but I don't like the eyes on the plushie itself so I don't
think I'm gonna get it.
It makes me so sad.
I think I pre-ordered a figure, a figure.
I just wish her eyes were different in the classroom.
Goofy, but not in a good way.